[Musique]
j'ai pas vu ces images depuis
enfin je crois je les ai peut-être
regarder en replay à l'époque une fois
mais je les ai jamais j'apprends
beaucoup le meilleur espoir féminin est
attribué à sara forestier
[Applaudissements]
des six nominations du film d'abdellatif
kechiche l'esquivé y joue l'héroïne du
film jon kyl et dans une semaine et qui
se prend de passion pour le théâtre en
jouant le jeu de l'amour et du hasard
je m'étais fait bronzer pour j'allais
faire ce prêt au timing pour cette
soirée
je m'étais fait pis je suis tout bronzé
je suis tous bords et 7,1 millions de
faits mais c'est drôle quoi j'étais pin
p j'avais des rajouts j'avais les
cheveux dorés
[Musique]
temenos
vous êtes magnifique moi je n'ai pas
calculé noir et c'était un culte il me
remet le prix je le remercie mais je me
rends pas compte du bonheur en fait de
qui ces merdes
je suis hyper honoré de recevoir ce
césar vraiment vraiment très honoré
parce que ce césar c'est une
reconnaissance de tout notre travail à
tous à toutes les personnes qui ont
travaillé sur ce film
et qu'est-ce que je suis contente je
n'avais pas un truc de fantasmes par
rapport au cinéma j'avais pas d'icône
j'avais pas je n'ai pas j'avais pas une
culture cinématographique très grande
c'est génial il ya des personnes que je
voudrais c'est tout particulièrement je
crois je vais en faire pleurer quelques
uns déjà sabrina seux saison je veux que
tu saches que je les partage avec toi
d'accord tout ce que tu as donné dans ce
film tout ce que tu as lu dans ce film
on va le partage les d'accord ensuite ça
et il y en a quelques-unes donc ça et je
vais m'en souvenir
marie monia je voudrais remercier parce
qu'avec 4 l'idée était là tous les jours
et il y avait un souci tu étais là bim
bim bim je leur amène là je les ramène
là était une vraie jeter bouger pour les
jeter choc et j'ai l'impression que
c'est pas moi en fait ses impressions
c'est une autre personne en fait c'est
incroyable je pensais pas j'étais hyper
sur deux mois déjà premièrement je suis
assez enfin je suis hyper étonné là où
je me reconnais c'est que j'ai remercié
vraiment des gens qui comptaient quoi
vraiment et le fait de remercier les
gens qui comptent c'est mille fois plus
classe que d'avoir une fausse modestie à
deux francs quoi vaut mieux être sincère
et et quitte à être un bulldozer mais au
moins est de droit voilà la belle
maintenant ça va être ta fête
je sais que tu aimes pas que je fasse la
faille hot mais alors c'est pas ça va
être bon ça abdel tu sais quoi
là je suis tranquille j'ai plus le trac
écoute moi bien un délit
tu es le plus grand génie que je
connaisse c'est simple pour la musique
classique
y'avait mozart pour l'europe il ya
belgique presley et pour le cinéma ya
toi abdel c'est à toi que je le dois
et je t'aime merci beaucoup a model
c'est pas quelqu'un qui est dans dans la
gloire et ça se passe ailleurs quoi donc
ça m'étonne pas du tout sa réaction moi
[Musique]
et j'étais ailleurs quoi je n'avais pas
conscience de de ce que c'était que
cette cérémonie de des gens du cinéma de
ges à 100 ça sent il ya un décalage le
souvenir que j'ai de cette soirée là qui
me revient en fait
abdel qu'il chiche on arrive au
fouquet's donc il a raflé tous les césar
et il se barre se marque mais moi je dis
j'aime recevoir les césar et je regarde
les gens jeudi mais il part on se barre
on part est en fait ouais il partait
s'est enfui et je savais pas à quoi
faire parce que j'étais hyper contente
en même temps il s'était joie là je
venais de rentrer dans le cinéma il y
avait que des gens du cinéma c'était la
soirée pour célébrer et en même temps
abdellah ce réflexe de partir et je suis
partie aussi du coup après un écrit à
bages passer chez moi je suis rentré
chez moi je suis rentré chez moi avec
mon césar vrai que j'ai mis dans ma
chambre de l'adolescent quand j'étais
adolescente j'avais quel âge quand j'ai
su que j'avais 18 ans je venais je crois
que j'avais 18 ans pas très longtemps
il ya des parties de nous qui meurent
aussi un en fonction de qui on est là
clairement je compte en tout cas une
petite partie de moi parce que parce que
parce que parce que oui je trouve qu'il
y avait un peu trop de y avait quelque
chose de bien dans cette assurance mais
il y avait quelque chose de trop en
force quoi en fait
mais vaut mieux ça que que de que de
pleurer et de prendre des pauses ou que
j'assume ça va